- Welcome back to "The
Kelly Clarkson Show."
I'm your guest host for
today, Howie Mandel.
With me is my friend
from "America's Got Talent Superstars,"
Terry Crews,
(audience cheers)
as well as my beautiful
daughter and co-host
of "Howie Mandel Does Stuff"
podcast, Jackie Schultz,
and like all children do eventually,
Jackie is now going to
take control from me,
so go ahead Jackie.
- Thanks, dad, if that's your real name.
So anyways, it is time for a
game that celebrates families
and all the wonderful nepotism
that goes along with them.
This is called Famous Family Funtimes.
- [Howie] Woo!
(audience cheers)
♪ Famous Family Funtimes ♪
- (laughs) Okay.
- All right, so here's how it works.
I'll read a sentence that
includes two first names
of famous people.
One is a parent and the
other is that parent's kid,
and what you guys have to do
is give me the last
name that connects them.
- Oh?
- Oh, okay.
- All right.
- Okay.
- First clue, they're stars
of stage and stars of screen.
Their names are Martin and Charlie--
(buzzer rings)
- Sheen!
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
You gotta hit the button.
- All right, next question.
If you take a walk
around the block,
you might run into Ethan and Maya--
(buzzer rings)
- Hawke.
(audience cheers)
- [Jackie] Yes!
- Okay, all right--
- [Howie] Wow--
- We get serious now.
- [Jackie] It's a tie.
- [Howie] It's a tie.
- Next question.
At Family Game Night, there is no loss
when you're playing with Diana
and Tracee Ellis--
(buzzer rings)
- Oh!
- Who did first?
- Me?
- I used to be her opening act, Ross.
- Yeah!
(audience cheers)
- I was Diana Ross' opening act!
- Mine didn't cycle out.
I gotta get my cycling out.
- Okay, ready?
Next question.
Once I give you this clue,
you'll give me some thanks
if you know the last
name of Tom and Colin--
(buzzer rings)
- Hanks!
(bell dings)
Hey, hey.
(audience cheers)
- Whoa, 2-2,
are you showing me 2-2
or is he saying, "Fun"--
- It's tied up.
It's 2-all, let's go y'all!
- "We're having fun."
- It's 2-all.
- All right, you ready
for the next question?
- I'm ready.
- Be careful you're not sorely mistaken
when you answer the name
of Sosie and Kevin--
(buzzer rings)
- Bacon, Bacon.
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
She was great in "Smile."
Did you see "Smile?"
She was great,
that's not a joke,
she was great in "Smile," the movie.
- Yeah, I know.
- She was in the movie.
She was in the movie.
- Okay, all right, come on.
- She was in a movie.
- This clue is much more
than just some filler,
it leads the last name of Ben--
- Ben Stiller.
- No!
(bell dings)
Wait, no,
(audience cheers)
you gotta say the question.
- Did you look?
- No, wait a minute,
no I didn't look,
but she said "filler" and,
I didn't cheat!
- You're the host,
of course you looked!
- But I didn't hear a rule
where you have to wait
for the question to end
if you figure it out.
- Can we get--
- You can't make up rules now.
No, I'm winning,
and I'm the host
and I don't care.
(Terry laughs)
- Next question--
- You can do what you want
on "America's Got Talent,"
I can do what I want here.
Wait till you see the prize
I'm gonna give myself,
cause I'm the host.
- Okay--
- I'm the host.
- This one's got my
head feeling a bit itchy
cuz I'm thinking of Nicole and Lionel--
- Richie!
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
Okay, we don't have to wait?
- He didn't wait til the end
of the question.
- We don't have to wait?
- We didn't get to the end--
- We don't have to wait anymore!
- We don't, but I'm still winning.
I'm still winning.
(Terry laughs)
- All right, next one.
Don't forget to repay all of your loans
if you owe money to Rashida and Quincy--
- Jones.
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
Sosie Bacon was in "Smile."
It's a horror movie.
(audience laughs)
(air horn blows)
- Whoa!
- Aw!
- Excuse yourself!
Excuse yourself!
- Four or five points on this last one?
You get 10 points on the last one.
- That means--
- She ate at a clown buffet
and it's upset her stomach.
(audience laughs)
- All right, this is your final question
and it's worth 10 points.
- Yes!
- It's worth 10 points.
- Yep, yep, yep.
- So anyone can win.
Everyone calm down,
don't have a cow,
it's all about Maude and Judd--
- Apatow.
- Apatow, no!
(bell dings)
(horn blares)
(audience cheers)
- Thank you, thank you.
(fanfare music)
- Okay, okay.
- Nice!
- What do you win?
What did you win?
- I win a podium.
(Crews laughs)
(audience cheers)
Thank you, thank you.
You get a cardboard cutout.
You can get a cardboard cutout of Kelly.
I'll be taking the podium.
(audience applauds)
I going to take this home.
I wanna take this home.
Let's do a commercial and
I'm gonna get this unhooked.
Thank you so much.
We wanted one.
My wife wants one
for the end of the bed
in the master bedroom.
(Crews laughs)
Are we ready to begin?
Remember, listen to "Howie
Mandel Does Stuff" podcast
wherever you get your podcasts,
and watch "America's Got
Talent All Stars" on NBC.